en este momento es muy probable que ya
estén familiarizados con la idea de
redondear probablemente ya lo
practicaron redondeando a la decena más
cercana ahora veremos otro tipo de
redondeo vamos a redondear a la centena
más cercana vamos a comenzar con un
ejemplo y verán que en muchos sentidos
es bastante parecido a redondear a la
decena más cercana sólo que ahora nos
fijamos en otros valores posicional es
digamos que tenemos el número 345 y lo
queremos redondear a la centena más
cercana pausa en el vídeo y traten de
aunque no les he enseñado cómo hacerlo
traten de intuir cuál será la centena
más cercana a 345 vamos a resolverlos
juntos lo primero que vamos a hacer es
ver la posición de las centenas vemos
que 345 tiene tres centenas cuatro
decenas y cinco unidades en 345 el
número de centenas que está justo por
debajo de 345 son tres centenas
está entre tres centenas cero decenas y
cero unidades y el número de centenas
que está por arriba de 345 son cuatro
centenas 345 está entre tres centenas y
cuatro centenas así queremos redondear
esto a la centena más cercana tenemos
que elegir una de estas dos para saber
cuál de estas dos vamos a elegir
tenemos que pensar si 345 es más cercano
a 400 o más cercano de 300 para pensar
en esto podemos dibujar una recta
numérica vamos a comenzar a enumerar
esta recta en 200 aquí esta 300 y acá
está 400 digamos que aquí está 350 y por
acá está 250 en donde se ubica 345 345
es un poco menor a 350 por lo que lo
dibujamos aquí cual centena es más
cercana a 345 300 o 400 visualmente
observamos que 350 está justo en medio
está a 50 unidades de 300 y a 50
unidades de 4
por lo que 345 está un poquito más
cercano a 300 así que en esta situación
en donde queremos redondear a la centena
más cercana vamos a redondear hacia
abajo a 300 otra forma de hacer esto es
algo muy parecido a lo que vimos cuando
aprendimos a redondear a la decena más
cercana si redondeamos a la centena más
cercana esto va a ser un 3 o un 4 y para
decidir cuál será tenemos que ver el
valor posicional menor a este en este
caso vemos el valor en la posición de
las escenas si el valor que está en la
posición de las decenas es menor a 5
entonces redondeamos hacia abajo si el
valor es igual o mayor a 5 entonces
redondeamos hacia arriba en este caso el
valor es menor a 5 por lo que
redondeamos hacia abajo si esto hubiera
sido 365 entonces sería mayor o igual a
5 por lo que hubiéramos redondeado hacia
arriba esto tiene sentido porque en la
recta numérica el 365 estaría por acá
que está más cercano a 400 veamos otro
ejemplo vamos a resolverlo de la forma
que acabo de
escribir y también con la recta numérica
ahora veremos un número de cuatro
dígitos para hacerlo más interesante
digamos que tenemos el número siete mil
652 pausa en el vídeo y traten de
redondear este número a la centena más
cercana vamos a resolverlo juntos
pensamos en la posición de las centenas
con lo que podemos ver esto como siete
millares y seis centenas o como 76
centenas cuál es la centena más cercana
a este número podemos verlo como 76
centenas 5 decenas y 2 unidades o como
siete millares seis centenas cinco
decenas y dos unidades de cualquier
forma la centena más cercana debajo de
este número es 76 centenas o siete mil
seiscientos y la centena que está arriba
de esta es una más que este 6 es decir
77 centenas a cuál vamos a redondear
podemos usar la técnica que les acabo de
enseñar donde vemos el valor en la
posición menor a la centena que en este
caso es la posición de las decenas y
vemos si este valor es mayor o igual a 5
si lo es entonces redondeamos
hacia arriba y si es menor a 5 entonces
redondeamos hacia abajo esto es mayor o
igual a 5 de hecho es igual a 5 por lo
que redondeamos hacia arriba a 7.700
también podemos ver esto en la recta
numérica vamos a dibujar una recta
numérica aquí comenzamos con 75 centenas
aquí están
setenta y seis centenas o siete mil
seiscientos y acá están siete mil
setecientos y aquí están siete mil 650
ahora siete mil 652 es un poco mayor a
esto por lo que estará más o menos por
acá y como vemos si está justo a la
mitad oa la derecha de la mitad entonces
vamos a redondear a 77 centenas que es
exactamente lo que acabamos de hacer
veamos otro ejemplo interesante vamos a
redondear a la centena más cercana a 982
a que será igual nuevamente nos fijamos
en la posición de las centenas cuál es
la centena que está debajo de 982 si
quitamos al 82 nos quedan 9 centenas son
9 centenas y redondeamos hacia abajo
y si redondeamos hacia arriba cuál es la
centena arriba de esta pues pasamos de 9
centenas a 10 centenas que es lo mismo
que un millar les quería mostrar este
ejemplo porque cuando redondeamos aquí
hacia arriba las siguientes centenas son
10 centenas un millar aquí podemos ver
muy claramente que al fijarnos en la
posición de las decenas el 8 es mayor o
igual a 5 por lo que redondeamos hacia
arriba 982 redondeado a la centena más
cercana es igual a un millar con esto
terminamos y nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo